hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game that just happened in
the final round of this year's Scutter
Masters it is the leader of the
tournament arasi who is leading the
tournament with six and a half points
and with a win in this round of course
he will be uh proclaimed Soul so leader
and the winner of the tournament if he
draws he has great chances of winning
the event as he will probably go into
tie breaks maybe with someone else and
NRE Beck is trailing by half a point
he's on Six Points so he will very much
enjoy Also winning which will put him in
intention for first place but uh you
know let's just check out the game and
see what happened because this is uh
this is sort of the definition of of a
hard break when it comes to chess so uh
let's check it out uh Notre Beck has the
white pieces and he opens with C4 he
goes for the English opening E6 the
ainur defense and Knight to C3 we have
D5 D4 and C6 transposing into the semi
Slava defense The Accelerated variation
uh E4 striking in the center D captures
Knight captures and Bishop to B4 check
we have Bishop to D2 captures sorry not
captures on D2 but rather Queen captures
on D4 a very exciting line Bishop
captures on B4 and the queen captures on
e4 with check we have Bishop to E2 and
now Knight to A6 so this is the main
move in the line and um Arjun plays it
he goes after the bishop so the black
queen is very active but the black king
cannot castle for the time being as the
bishop is controlling this diagonal so
Bishop to D6 even allowing Queen captur
on G2 and now a common move here is
Queen to D2 but here we have Bishop to
F3 going after the queen right away
Queen to G5 and now Knight to E2 we have
Knight A7 uh getting ready to the castle
and now Knight to G3 and here there is a
game where Queen to A5 check was played
but here we have Pawn to E5 and it is
now as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game so okay Notre goes
Queen to B3 uh and now getting ready to
get the Rook into the game also puts
pressure on Black's Queen side that B7
Pawn could be hanging if the bishop is
developed so all in all it's a very nice
move but again Queen to A3 might be the
the key move as it will put even more
pressure on the Knight and on this
diagonal so castles uh and now we have
Pawn to H4 first attacking the black
queen queen F6 and Knight to E4
attacking the queen while defending the
Knight and the bishop on D6 we have
Queen to E6 and now Queens side Castle
so look at this Not Afraid of Anything
uh he wants to put the Rooks on the G
file and go after that black King we
have Rook to E8 and now Rook H to G1 and
here nrec spent maybe maybe 4 minutes on
the clock he had like 2 minutes 2 hours
and 26 minutes on the clock whereas um
sorry an hour and 26 minutes on the
clock whereas uh Arjun is already down
to 1 hour and 6 minutes so he's trying
to figure out everything that's
happening here and one way you could
play it uh is for example Pawn to C5
it's a very tricky move but then you get
Bishop captures on E7 and after Queen
captures then the Knight comes to D6 and
this is just very annoying attacking the
rook and also there's a triple attack on
the B7 Pawn now maybe something to avoid
for example if Rook to d8 you will play
Bishop captures on B7 and now you don't
have anything better than Rook captures
on D6 Bishop captures on A8 and the
white will just be better so uh the only
real way to try is Knight to F5 not
allow to capture and put pressure on
that Bishop on D6 so okay we have Bishop
to H5 uh again played pretty much
instantly so you know that when and you
see such a move that obviously not is
still well within his preparation and uh
what is the idea I mean is it Queen to
H6 check is that just a blunder of a
piece obviously not as these are very
strong players but let's just check what
happens uh if King to B1 and queen
captures Knight to F6 check uh of course
the G Pawn is pinned so you will just
win the black queen however you could
play it and it in fact is the strongest
move but you have to play Knight
captures on D6 now and after Rook
captures on D6 going after the queen now
you play Queen F4 go after the Knight
and after Knight to F6 check you give up
the exchange here King f8 Knight
captures on E8 King captures on E8 and
now if Rook captures on G7 which looks
like you should be able to play uh
there's this bishop to F5 check move and
now it's white who could be in trouble
you can't go here because of Queen to C1
Checkmate so you have to block with the
Rook uh and now Knight C5 attacks Rook
attacks the queen defends on B7 and it's
a a very nice uh defense for black and
if Rook captures on F7 which looks
really awesome then Bishop captures on
D3 with check Queen captures Knight
captures and now Rook captures on F4
King to E7 as you've opened up a
discovery so King to E7 Rook to F7 check
let's say King to E6 uh sorry King to E6
Rook captur on B7 and now even Pawn to
E4 you get this position where white
will be up a pawn but black can very
much play this okay you can even capture
on H7 but then Knight captures on F2
creates a pass Pawn black has sufficient
counterplay for uh his uh him being done
a pawn however Knight to D4 was played
here and this is uh well a very a very
interesting line maybe not even a
suboptimal line but a very interesting
one it's hard to even measure uh these
positions with a standard engine because
who knows on on what engine uh Notre
Beck prepared this so you know the more
you allow the engine to Crunch the
numbers the the you know crazier
variations the the engine gives you so
here okay the queen is attacked you also
have to keep ey keep an eye on the C4
Pawn so Queen to D3 now G6 of course you
have to play this uh you do weaken the
F6 square but you have to get rid of the
the weaknesses on the G file also you
put pressure on the bishop Pawn to F4
again played really quickly and now Pawn
to C5 and now the situation is an hour
and 16 minutes for NRE backck and only
22 minutes for Arjun so that's how much
time Arjun had to spend in order to
figure out everything he needs on how to
get out of this position so let's see if
he was able to do it f captures on E5
Knight to B4 now attacking the queen and
now you really have to be careful if
Queen captures on C4 lands with the two
knights and the queen you're going to
lose the game so Queen F1 the only move
that holds and now Queen to F5 uh
defending everything uh but also
allowing um Norbeck sort of uh win the
game but you have to be very very
precise this is the first pause the
video of the game so feel free to pause
the video and try to find the absolute
best move for Notre Beck while I give
you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
this uh Beauty And for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Rook
captures on D4 that's the move and NRE
Beck played it and now there are two
lines that you have to check C captures
on D4 being one of them okay you could
play Queen captures on F1 but that will
not work and Knight captures an A2 check
now let's check why this doesn't work
the problem is that the Knight gets
stranded on A2 not even because of the
king the king will move to D2 and now
after C captures on D4 Knight to F6 with
check King to h8 Knight captures on E8
now going for Knight to C7 uh so the
other Rook might hang as well and after
Queen captures on F1 Rook captures on F1
and now Bishop to H3 going after the
Rook Rook to F3 and now Rook captures on
E8 we have Rook captures on H3 G
captures on H5 and now Rook to A3 this
is what strands the Knight on A2 so
that's why this is impossible so here we
have C captures on D4 and now Knight to
F6 with check we have King to h8 and the
bishop captures on B4 H so just uh
winning that um Knight on B4 Rook
captures on E5 and now Bishop back to D1
getting the bishop out of Harm's Way
Bishop to E6 and now Bishop to D6
attacking the rook and here the problem
is there's really not all that much you
can do arjun's POS sorry not's position
is just so much better uh but Arjun
manages to find a way how to complicate
he plays Bishop captures on C4 and he
attacks arjun's Queen on F1 and now
there is only one way to win this feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for Arjun uh sorry for NRE Beck while I
give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding this uh
wild wild idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is uh not
Knight to G4 this is what NRE Beck
played the actual move that wins the
game is Bishop captures on E5 and now
the point is if Queen captures on F1
then you play uh then there's really
nothing happening here just Rook
captures on F1 and after Bishop captures
uh you will play Bishop to F3 and you
have um excellent compensation and you
also have the the black king completely
pinned in the corner uh not much to be
done here uh but there's even a better
way to do it after Bishop captures on uh
on E5 uh if you go for Queen captures on
F1 then of course Rook captures on F1
and if Bishop captures an F1 there's
Bishop to F3 uh sorry I I I think I just
show you the line that I've already
played the idea of Bishop captures on F1
is the one we have to check and now
Knight to G4 check yeah that's why you
you get out of it and then after Queen
captures on E5 then comes Knight
captures on E5 and after let's say Rook
to C8 check which doesn't really do
anything King to D2 and now your
position will be winning you will have a
rook and a rook Knight and Bishop versus
a rook and Bishop and here most
interestingly he went for a different uh
type of exchange one that uh sort of
leaves him with less material he played
Knight to G4 and now look at this queen
captures on F1 Bishop captures on E5
with check King to G8 and now Rook
captures on F1 we have Bishop captures
on F1 and now Knight to F6 with check
King to G7 and now King to D2 uh Bishop
to G2 was played and now Pawn to B4 so
now instead of having a rook bishop and
Knight versus rook and Bishop he has a
bishop pair and Knight versus rook and
Bishop so also not terrible but not as
great we have Pawn to H6 and now Bishop
to B3 we have King to f8 now comes
Bishop captures on D4 and King A7 and
here it's 31 minutes on the clock for
nrec and only 4 minutes for Arjun Nigi
and he has to figure out how to survive
five more moves until uh he reaches time
control uh and here King to E3 was
played uh interestingly Knight to G4 is
a really wild move because black has to
Black has to figure out how to defend
this if you play uh if you play Pawn to
H5 then df7 Pawn is in trouble because
you will play Bishop to F6 with check
and now uh sorry uh you will play Bishop
to C5 with check and now with the bishop
controlling this diagonal the Knight
controlling F6 and with the bishop
controlling this diagonal you will have
no way of Defending that pawn if King
moves here you'll just deliver a check
King has to move and then the light
Square pawns are going to fall so the
only way to handle Knight to G4 is to
play King to f8 and okay then the game
continues Knight captures on H6 maybe
but there are better moves but uh King
to f8 not an easy move to spot however
Arjun uh sorry notbe continued with King
to E3 and now Pawn to B6 we have Knight
to G4 and now Bishop to H3 we have King
to F4 and now Pawn to G5 with check H
captures H captures and King to G3 now
of course you cannot capture on G5 if
you capture on G5 then Rook to G8 check
just picks up the Knight here even if
you go after the bishop then it's even
worse captures captures and you lose the
bishop on D4 and then the rook and extra
Pawn will defeat the light Square Bishop
so here after this H captures and G5
move we have King to G3 by Norbeck uh
and now Bishop captures on G4 King
captures and now Rook to d8 going after
the bishop and now you have to go for
Bishop to A1 it's the only way to play
otherwise you will be able to uh go
after that Bishop combin it with a
combine the attack for example if you go
Bishop to B2 then you will go after the
bishop with Rook to D2 then you go Rook
to G2 and your Pawn is defended you will
solidify with F6 and that's very good
for black so uh Notre Beck plays the
only good move and that is Bishop to A1
now we have Rook to D3 and King captures
on G5 we have Pawn to A5 and here it
seems that you will have um sufficient
compensation for the draw uh because
even if okay black might have this pass
Pawn doesn't really matter you will give
up one of the Bishops for this Pawn the
other Bishop for one of the pawns on the
queen side and let's say white is left
with a
uh so you will give up your Bishop for
um uh the pawn here
and it's not going to be possible
because if the Rook um uh if uh you are
left with u a bishop and the pawn you
will not be able to escort it for
example a dark Square bishop and the
light a pawn that ends on a light Square
uh of course that will be a draw so
there are plenty of ways you can draw
this however uh B captures on A5 was
played B5 also not really spectacular
because King D6 and the King will be
able to win that pawn so B captures on
A5 was played B captures on A5 and now
Bishop to C4 attacking The Rook here
Rook to D2 and King to F4 H we have Pawn
to A4 now comes Bishop to C3 attacking
the rook and Rook to H2 going after Rook
to H4 check to win the bishop here so
King to F5 and now believe it or not uh
it's still a complete a dead draw for
example Rook C2 you go after the Bishops
you deliver one check and okay then the
game continues the bishop moves and we
continue playing however after King to
F5 a total heartbreak for uh for Arjun
he played Rook to H4 and now of course
you guys don't even need to pause the
video to figure out what happened here
of course um notbe played it instantly
Bishop to F6 with check and he was in
this position un move 49 that Arjun
arigi resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so Arjun
went into the final round as the leader
of the tournament he played an
exceptional tournament and now after
Rook H4 uh he just loses his chances of
actually winning the event and Norbeck
is now half a point Point ahead of
everyone else and it's going to be
probably a tie break between him and
whoever wins um on some of the other
boards that are that are still playing I
can just quickly check uh what's the
current situation so let me just do that
real quickly okay so they are still
playing um let me just
check uh yeah yakub and kikan uh and
kikan are still playing and it will
definitely be decided there so currently
we have abdat seven and then a whole
bunch of people on six and a half like
Naran and syaro Nakamura arj also on six
and a half even after losing the final
game param makulu and gkes uh so yeah a
big heartbreak for Arjun but you know
props another back for uh playing you
know he had a winning position he
couldn't win it he went for maybe a
suboptimal line but in the end you know
uh the two Bishops overpowered the The
Rook uh so yeah that's the game hope you
enjoyed it U very nicely done by Norbeck
uh we're going to check up on the
tournament after all of the games have
finished to keep you updated and
remember today we're in some two two
hours time we will be having a
simultaneous exhibition ala fua will be
taking on uh 20 of our improvers so if
you have any questions for ala join the
live stream we can also ask him whatever
you guys are interested in and also it
will you know help us defeat him as you
know it might give our improvers uh you
know a head start against them uh so
yeah once again hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank your mom's modern
mate tuer bman Eddie Indus bullet
thriller.com and Chad Smith for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day